les gens du grand montréal auront une
infrastructure de longue durée et de
haute qualité
si on nous promet un futur pont
champlain à la fine pointe son béton
sera pourtant bientôt dépasser des
bétons encore peu utilisée au canada
seraient trois à quatre fois plus
résistant que ceux employés présentement
il s'agit des béton fibré ultra
performant dbf hulpe et où des buffles
comme s'emploie à dire ces deux
ingénieurs de l'école polytechnique de
montréal depuis 2006 maintenant qu'il se
penche sur ces bétons mélangé à de
petites particules dassier qui freinent
le développement des futures et de la
corrosion causée par les charges
routière et les conditions climatiques
et s'il devait y en avoir
malgré une ouverture de fissures aussi
importante les fibres continues à
maintenir les deux blocs ensemble et ce
béton le bf hulpe et pourrait procurer
une durabilité de 150 ans même plus pour
le futur pont champlain infrastructure
canada dit avoir imposé un béton moins
résistants mais à haute performance un
bhp
car celui ci est plus résistant la
pénétration du sel aux cycles de gel
dégel et à l'abrasion que les bétons
conventionnel mais cette technologie
date de la fin des années 80 et poserait
des risques de fissure l'utilisation des
temps aux performances les baies hp vont
nous permettre de se rendre assez loin
mais on devra probablement faire des
réparations au bout de 50 60 ans
assurément parce que le béton bois se
vaut quand même se détériorer plus
rapidement qu'un bien futé pour parvenir
à la durabilité promise de 125 ans le
ministère dit miser sur des armatures en
acier inoxydable et ordinaire le conseil
national de recherches du canada
consultée dans le dossier croit que ces
armatures seront suffisantes mais qu'un
bf huppé offrirait la totale
c'est une solution viable qui pourraient
être utilisés pour les éléments
importants de
les dalles les poutres et les poteaux
les gouvernements font valoir que des
essais sont encore nécessaires au canada
pour mieux connaître les propriétés des
bf super pourtant commercialisés en
europe et aux états unis par la firme
lafarge com ici pour refaire la surface
des viaducs de chillon en suisse les
connaissances actuelles font en sorte
que nous pouvons utiliser ces mariés
matériaux ici sur nos infrastructures
par contre nous mettre d'ouvreur
actuellement c'est à dire la ville de
montréal société des ponts champlain et
jacques-cartier et mystérieux transport
préfèrent actuellement y aller dans un
mode pas à pas de faire des projets
pilotes à l'ère des grands projets à
montréal turcs ou champlain serait-il
encore temps c'est béton là à l'endroit
où les utiliser plus dans les derniers
éléments qui vont être installées donc
d'un probablement dans la dernière année
est ce que dans la volonté du
propriétaire du virage et dans l'intérêt
aussi dans l'entreprise de construction
faudra éventuellement ce sera une
question de choix indique cet ingénieur
à la ville de montréal la métropole
s'apprête à construire un pont
piétonnier en b est super bien que plus
dispendieux parfois le matériau le plus
économique est celui qui fait peut-être
le plus cher initialement allons
investir initialement 10 % à 20 % de
plus sur une phrase peut-être la plus
grande économie qu'une ville ne font
jamais sur univers si on peut faire deux
fois sa durée de vie par rapport à un
usage conventionnel chez l'un des rares
fournisseurs de ce béton au québec
son utilisation dans nos infrastructures
passe par un travail de longue haleine
si convaincante h1n1 euros.le donc les
nomades ouvrages et les consultants
puissent les entreprenants règle
générale ce qu'on peut penser que la
politique du plus bas soumissionnaire
permet pas nécessairement de
d'introduire aisément
des technologies nouvelles ça veut pas
dire que c'est pour faisait amener sa
panne ne travaille en amont
le bf upi suscite donc beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé chez les ingénieurs en
effet beaucoup se désole de la
dégradation rapide de nos
infrastructures
pour preuve les travaux de réfection de
ce mur de béton du tunnel ville marie
ont été réalisés il ya moins de 6 ans et
déjà des fissures sont perceptibles à
l'onu mathieu il faut dire ici qu'on a
demandé bien sûr une entrevue avec
infrastructure canada le donneur
d'ouvragé
ils ont après plusieurs tentatives de
notre part décliner et viennent de vous
envoyer un texte
voilà je leur ai demandé à deux reprises
s'il pensait du bf huppé et m'ont
toujours répondu que le bhb puisque vous
êtes spécialiste maintenant que le bhp a
été imposé pour la construction du futur
pont champlain
or après avoir hésité pour une troisième
fois nous avons une réponse aujourd'hui
alors le groupe est ce celle qu'est le
groupe signature sur saint laurent
le consortium formé par snc lavalin pour
construire le futur pont champlain peut
maintenant choisir le type de béton qui
jugent le plus approprié pour répondre
aux exigences du gouvernement
que ce soit du bf huppé ou toute autre
catégorie de bétons à hautes
performances
donc on ouvre la porte à l'anc on ne le
faisait pas on ouvre la porte peut-être
à l'utilisation de ce nouveau superbe et
on sait ce qu'on comprend c'est ce qu'on
peut en déduire pour le moment avec ce
courrier effective
merci à mathieu de ce dossier on va
conclure avec son levier on l'a vu dans
le reportage de matthieu bruno
massicotte vous est peut-être le plus
grand expert du btan merci et on a un
morceau de ce nouveau béton là le
superbe et on est on voit très bien ici
qu'il est comme des comme le principe
des plus y'a plein de filaments là c'est
ce qui fait que indestructible
effectivement lorsqu'on introduit dans
le béton c'est faible de 6 et des très
petites fibres c'est les mêmes films
qu'on retrouve dans l'hypnose
effectivement c'est exactement les mêmes
ça donne ça confère au béton très très
bonne résistance à la traction temps que
celle l'empêchent de fissurer
sous les charges normale parce qu'il
faut rappeler monsieur massicotte que le
pont champlain dont on parle il ya
cinquante ans est absolument anormal que
l'on doive refaire un ton après une si
courte période
est-ce que avec le principe du plus bas
soumissionnaire on l'a vu dans le
reportage est ce que le risque c'est de
ne pas encore une fois marqué le coup en
mettant pascal meyer
c'est ce que le en ayant le plus bas
soumissionnaire on a le l'entreprise a
tout avantage à optimiser ses coûts au
maximum
et c'est toujours plus difficile
d'introduire de nouvelles technologies
des technologies qu'il m'aurait
peut-être plus de risques dans ce cas là
donc c'est peut-être là conditions
idéales pour pouvoir introduire des
nouvelles technologies des technologies
émergentes et favoriser l'innovation
êtes vous d'accord que si on paie plus
au départ ça peut être payant sur le
long terme c'est toujours payant sur le
long terme sociaux et on parle le plus
mais sait pas beaucoup plus sur le puits
le nouveau rage comme ça ça se compte
peut-être quelques pour ça même
peut-être plus qu'un cours légal donc
donc le coût initial est relativement
faible et c'est sûr que ça va être
rentable tant que mascotte pour vous il
ya aucun doute les fougerais de le
toucher parce qu'elles vendent ils
piquent y aucun doute que ça serait
beaucoup plus efficace et durable pour
le nouveau pont champlain
ça c'est un béton qui au moins trois
fois plus du rêve que les meilleurs
béton qui sont pas fils riz donc ça
c'est dans les antilles au moins trois
fois plus c'est même un peu plus que
trois bandits minimalement à 3 donc si
on pense qu'un béton va durer 60 à 100
l'opération lui vont pouvoir durer
encore beaucoup plus longtemps donc je
veux pas vous mettre des mots dans la
bouche la met donc ça serait quand on
regarde ça une erreur de ne pas aller
avec ce qu'il put résistant sur un
ouvrage comme le nouveau pont oui non ce
serait en fait c'est un matériau qui est
utilisée ailleurs dans le monde ici on
commence à l'utiliser
ce sera peut-être une erreur de vouloir
l'utiliser à grande échelle trop
rapidement donc les nouvelles
technologies ont besoin d'être
introduite progressivement et c'est pour
ça que le ministère des transports la
ville de montréal plongea quartier
chantenay sont impliqués dans des
projets pilotes à plus petite échelle
vraiment beaucoup plus petit mais pour
s'assurer que les ingénieurs les
ouvriers tout le monde comprenne bien la
façon dont une utilisée nouveau des
temps donc on aurait pu l'utiliser mais
on aurait besoin d'un période de trois
années
pour se faire la main on voyait que la
réponse du donneur d'ouvragé change et
l'on ouvre la porte
est ce à dire que de l'espoir pour les
contribuables de se faire dire dans
quelques semaines bon mais finalement on
va mettre ce qu'il ya de plus résistants
pour le prochain plaît c'est
d'inscription pour le pont champlain
c'est un conte ok déjà été accordés donc
sa veste le choix de celui qui a reçu le
contrat que qu'ils aient quitté à qui on
accordait comptera donc c'est lui qui à
le construire et à l'entretenir vers le
remède est en meilleur état si lui juge
que peut-être un avantage parce que
moins de réparations à faire dans
l'année où il aurait la propriété de
l'ouvragé est l'heureux l'entretenir
peut-être que ce sera un choix aussi
pour eux que ce sera même peut-être le
plus rentable pour cette entreprise
locale a terminé monsieur dans l'avenir
du sycot 1 5-10 ans vous croyez que ça
ça va être la norme
j'espère que dans cinq ans on savait 12
h cour fait pas surplus ouvrage mais
qu'on aurait atteint un degré de
confiance une expertise aussi parce que
l'on peut bien l'utiliser on peut aussi
de mal utiliser donc faut acquérir
l'expérience progressivement et j'espère
que d'ici cinq ans on avale expertise
suffisante pour pouvoir l'utiliser à
plus grande échelle
je m'excuse merci beaucoup fort
intéressant pour va suivre ça et fluide
amant pour ce qui est du pont champlain
mais ailleurs d'autres projets merci de
venir sur le plateau avec votre morceau
de l'intervention l'un des messieurs
comme art